[Music]
if you do happen to speak with any
reporters just stay on message and what
is that message
SJP is a mentorship is that sgp endorses
the protesters are on a fellowship
program run by a conservative think tank
called the hoover institution basically
just like no Apollo coming in the egg
block there are these jihadis who
basically a suicide bombing and they're
on a campus and you have to stop them so
I chase the shadow here is Noah Pollak
is at the center of a neoconservative
Pro Likud political network in
Washington that represents the right
wing of the pro-israel lobby he is
collaborated with neoconservative
think-tank in Washington the Hoover
Institution to basically pay fake
protesters to make it look like people
are coming out and protesting Palestine
activity in Washington do my worst
nightmare is actually not kidding is a
photo Jian and I together and we're just
so I clearly identifiable and they're
like all were these like traitors
yeah astroturfing is when corporations
or political movements basically pay for
grassroots support this is what is so
revealing about the Israel lobby in
America is that they basically pay for
congressional support for through
donations though they even are willing
to pay low-level people to go out on the
streets that make it look like common
Americans actually support the Israel
lobbies goals when they really don't
[Music]
I'm distressed to find that our
investigation into America's pro-israel
lobbyists may represent the most
important test yet of al-jazeera's
independence and whether our network
still has space to thrive amidst the
unjust blockade against our Qatari host
[Music]
you